right Bryan to that past Oh Brian Regan
sit down sit down
hey what's going on man what's up a
Kanye West mental illness [ __ ] how he
got mad at ariana grande for jumping in
right then he got throw at this guy
then he got mad again at Drake he was
tweeting him for dissing him in songs
and talking about his shoes he said if
you insult my shoes and your songs
you're taking food out of my kids mouth
you can't you can't do that that's
crossing the line
what a [ __ ] baby - it's not the man's
shoes that he makes and then he got mad
at ariana grande - what did she do she
tweeted out something about a Kanye's
mental illness oh and then he was like
hey keep my name out your mouth hey stop
talking about it that if you don't
people to be fun of it well I think he's
going on man again all I know is the
guy's got the most ridiculous shoes you
mean these bad boys they are but look at
them is writing on and they've even
finished semi-frozen semi-frozen yellow
is good do you like that Brian
III was completely Joe kind of jump in
with a little shoe joke because that was
the topic stenciled riding on the
prototype now they're not exact words a
little bit of destruction like stupid
you think so hate him no they're a
little much too flashy yeah well I'm a
flashy guy mark
yeah the backwards writing on them we
got a couple dad those are Prada
yeah that's a that's a little flashy I'm
proud of my product you should me uh-huh
that means you're doing all right and
when when people look down on the street
they're like that's a guy who's who's
found quite a bit of success for himself
well they say you can tell whether
somebody's how somebody's doing by their
shoes that's right crap my dad actually
has those New Balances Marsh yeah I love
a good dad shoe very comfy yes oh my god
practical and fans are maybe the worst
shoes I've ever seen in my look like an
old catcher's mitt thank you let me see
what are those they're air Orphanage
[Laughter]
minor off some okay adidas I'm good with
gyms gyms correct with those work
yeah sketches game is no good those are
Skechers yeah look at an old football
helmet from the 40s that's right
I got Clooney movie that he had yeah
earth shoes North shoes maybe I'm dating
myself but they had like these weird
kind of shoes that were shaped oddly I
don't know if it had to do with somebody
having a foot disorder there we go yeah
what was the point of them I suck I
think I think it was much too walk more
naturally than people do with normal
shoes now so they went on over ration
yeah but they look they'd look horriffic
did you have a pair no I didn't but
there was some guys in my class growing
up that it was hard for me to learn
because I'm just looking at these guys
have you ever considered did you ever
consider going the route of the toe
finger shoes you know I'm trying to
ninjas yeah yeah they look very
uncomfortable no I would never never
never know
hey guys are weird who do that yeah it
feels like you're wearing like spandex
tights or something like yeah who needs
your courage what is that for running I
guess so but I feel like there's zero
support them it's all part of that
philosophy we're like people had it
figured out 65 thousand years ago they
[ __ ] ate berries they died when they
were 20 yeah [ __ ] yeah did fire was a
big deal
then in their defense fair enough and
they had rocks nothing to work with it
but their paintings were garbage sure
it's like they still had eyes they're
gonna paint the acceptable they're
literally named after their houses they
lived in caves and then just called
caveman there's nothing remarkable about
anything yeah that they did yeah so
let's not like act like the caveman diet
with the food I'd like a paleo diet yeah
yeah please have the ability to do
anything
people love to pay no people of the keto
diet right Cheetos big Quito is huge
because you can eat bacon but no sugar I
think yeah those bacon has sugar in it
less it's a certain type I eat a little
bit of bacon if you want the truth I do
[Laughter]
the show Thank You PO have you ever
tried right Sam go comment I was gonna
ask if you've ever tried any of these
celebrity diets I never have no I eat I
eat incredibly poorly mmm yeah they look
good well thank you big thick overcoat
with a zipper you know a Krispy Kreme
Doughnuts
I eat Chef Boyardee spaghetti and
meatballs cold out of the canyon Wow a
[Laughter]
lot of you were just checking to see if
he's being sarcastic you found out he
wasn't you're like you know what's sad
is what I do is stay in a lot of hotels
and hotels now have that little little
shopping that's right a little love the
little treat area oh yeah but they
always have like a can of chunky and
I'll just buy one chunky soup and eat it
and they'll in the room and there's no
microwave in the room so I just drink it
wow that's cold eat it cold ramen so
good I love it
really I love it that sounds so like you
know how many lonely nights I've had in
those type of hotel like just hearing
that gives me [ __ ] like a like
flashbacks to the entire
last twelve just being alone in his
hotel lobby it's stinking cold I was in
a hotel one time and it was a nice hotel
but I still like the chef boyardee so I
had bought that like after service so
you had a good show you want to treat
yourself I would treat myself so I got
two cans of Chef Boyardee spaghetti and
then we went out and I got a little
drunk and then I go back to the hotel
and there was no fork so I had to call
down to ask for a fork with a drunken
slur and I called the front desk and I
am 47 oh [ __ ] actually came up with you
know and they try to try to make it as
presentable as possible you know like
like put it on a cloth or a shirt
here's your fork I love you just
slipping into panic though because in
your drunken stupor you're like I can't
have them heat it up I want to like it I
don't like it hot I like it cold a
coagulated spaghetti it's it's very good
you don't phrase it like that yeah I
don't I don't think of it as coagulated
I'll start eating I mean you're drunk
and you're eating cold spaghetti out of
a care what are your shits look like no
I kind of think Brian is the this is the
American dream to get to this point in
your life where you're very successful
in your in your chosen field yeah you're
living the dream then you get to go home
and get drunk and eat cold SpaghettiOs I
mean you're here brian has a special
promoting he's brownie stand up away
stand up and away with Brian me gets a
new Netflix comedy always the series on
this eve Oh what is it about it's a
hyper comedy series that blends Brian's
stand-up with short sketches an audience
interaction Jim
Oh Jerry Seinfeld has nothing to do with
it no no no actually is an executive
producer
look at that yes I'm very fortunate that
he wanted to back this thing and the
Netflix people said yes and so it's a
four episode series each one is about a
half-hour and and that's the deal that's
great what so what you just do like
little bits here and there in between
sketches that are based on your material
I I do a lot of my older stand-up bits
and then I will segue from that into a
sketch about whatever and come up with
some type of transition okay so the
sketches are I mean the sketch they're
just based on the battle no silly it's
not that you do the bit and a sketch
about the bit no no I want the stand up
to remain the stand up I end up should
be stand up I don't like messing with
that I don't like to make sketch
versions of state up comedy routines so
I do the stand-up and then we have some
type of segue for example I do my
ironing board bit and then we do a
parody of Shark Tank about somebody
trying to pitch the ironing board ties
in there yes I'm there it Shark Tank
parody I'm there yeah and I know you the
guy making the pitch yes that's cool you
don't use a stand-up is sometimes you
know you watch it a pilot of a sitcom
and it's so forced that they're shoving
in this guy's Act oh yeah I love that
then you see all the hard work at the
Laugh Factory every night talking about
bringing this for a living you like guys
the fruits of his labor shitty ABC show
it is crazy that guys try to build a
whole career on a seven-minute set and
they think like this will be like show
the guy who does this and do people
still do that I know that that was like
big for a period of time is that so
not as much I mean maybe they do it I
you know it's just it's what people have
been trained to do the sitcom world
there's a lot smaller than it used to be
oh yeah there used to be a money
printing machine and now it's tough to
get them to work I guess the consumers
out there I still want to be in a signal
I want to be the funny neighbor is that
why you you enter the stage the like
that when you do chip every single time
that's right hey everybody entrance be a
great neighbor chip do you think that
could be a sitcom
what your chip guy tell its head should
be a series of movies like the Lord of
the Rings
giant budget shot by Peter Jackson
Overland is this water fair game yeah a
game if it's sealed it's yours man we
lift at room temp we know you like this
how do you feel about animating stand
ups you like to leave standing up alone
in terms of writing sketches you know
around and everything but how do you
feel when you just take the bit
meaning you don't you leave the bit as
it is but you animate around it so that
it adds all the visual and everything I
think stand-up comedy by itself already
you're saying words and then the
audience is forming the pictures so I
think when you when somebody else
creates the pictures it's different from
from what the stand-up is sometimes it's
done well like the Jonathan Katz thing
oh yeah oh yeah yeah IIIi was on that
and I loved what they did with it um but
there are other times I've seen my stuff
animated and I'm like he didn't love me
right yeah no they get wrong what do you
think they got wrong when I've seen when
you didn't like it when you didn't like
it what do you think was wrong well they
somebody animated my thing where I was
talking about my mom and the way they
drew my mom I wasn't happy about it why
what did your own they make her too hot
or too I'm attracted to this cartoon
version of my shouldn't be going into
this but you know I love my mom she's a
wonderful person and they they kind of
day had her like with a cigarette
dangling out of her mouth and I'm like
my mom doesn't smoke you know so I guess
yes you you when you're writing the joke
even if it's at your mom's expense you
can kind of protect her a little bit and
then when somebody else has that visual
all of a sudden for protection isn't
there adding a layer yeah of something
to it that that I didn't have in my mind
when I told the joke that makes sense
they just trying to make a cartoon
friendly or silly or right right and
everybody's gonna laugh at a cigarette
dangling from the mouth good this mama
this cigarette thing she must be a
horrible
so do you hope is part of you hoping
that if you do these bits on Netflix
then you'll be able to go out and people
won't ask for the bits anymore that tire
the bit once they're on Netflix trysting
that's that's actually an interesting
question because I'm honored that people
like to hear these but I thought this
would be a way to kind of put them to
bed yeah I mean I went but but in it
hopefully an interesting way words yeah
well I wonder what sketch they're gonna
do after this bit you know I mean
totally tell so they'll see the bit like
I stand up and then see some sketch you
go okay that's that ties in sort of and
then I can kind of move away from you're
trying to basically behead these bits
like the Freebirds of comedy yeah I've
always been you know happy that people
like to hear them but it's like it's
bizarre to me do you like in an airport
and some of us say is the yellow on the
Sun turnaround I think of that all the
time or you're poor visit I think of
that joke yeah yeah you know it's weird
like the u2 thing is not that I just
happen to do the bit a long time ago
with but it's a very easy thing that
would happen to anybody
that's why anybody that says that if you
have any comedic mind would go hey man
that could be funny so people tweet you
to references and put a program and
people are always coming to my defense
like they're like they're angry with
these people going hey that's Brian
Riggins bit you know and it's like calm
down man you know it's like somebody is
literally I've had that experience I was
out with a girl and she's like you have
a nice dick and I said you two I do I
worry about you a little bit and I have
to warn you that I talked to Bert
Kreischer about the same thing he said
about not about a you know retiring bits
right right and he said he did the
Machine story on Showtime thinking that
he could do the Machine story on
Showtime that way put it to bed never
have to do it again he loves that
everybody loves his story but right
so what happened was he did the story
and then they cut that out they put it
on Facebook yeah it went completely
viral like that was way bigger than his
special it got like millions and
millions and millions of hits and now
now he really can't go anywhere right
without people wanting me hear the
Machine so does does he does he end up
and every show by doing he doesn't have
the special although they know anything
Dave yeah they clipped it and they put
it on Facebook and it went crazy vibe
yeah yeah yeah and now yeah now he now
he thought that before it was a pain in
the ass but now he's like no now
everywhere I go people want to hear it
it's a good thing I mean it's it's it's
a good bra garnered him a new audience
and everything but but you got to keep
doing the bits Jim that you have to do
all the time that people always yell out
hey man yeah it's this thing I do where
I say I appreciate you guys coming good
night start demanding at five minutes in
do the big closer shamefully Duck and
wave like I'm accepting a standing
ovation
the person who booked books you goes do
you do an encore and you go and you know
it's never come up it's never actually
tried but by the time I get there all
their backs you do though I've seen you
perform and you do absolutely have
people yelling out chip every time you
go on and they have you have to kind of
tell them no I'm gonna do chip and yeah
and because I can't follow but they
wanted they go to Jim and they want to
see him do the chip care yeah yeah I'll
do yeah I mean I don't know doing it
it's weird to do without their I saw you
years ago you handled it really really
well I saw you in Syracuse years ago not
you job and and you did a thing we're at
the very beginning of the show you said
I'll take requests at the end and it
kept people from well if they start
shouting out right when I hit the stage
yeah I can't I can't do one of those
bits because then it's a hootenanny
right I mean right
so I have to shut it down yeah because
this way and plus your thumb is that you
want to do your new stuff it's finally
exactly at the normal hour is the stuff
from the last couple years yeah
now we're doing a sketch show is it
something you wanted to do for a long
time or was it just like this idea came
up and you were like yeah that's that
that could be really great no because my
stand-up bits are when you look at them
they're like little vignettes anyway
they're just like little one-minute
things and I realized years ago that the
they're like little plays but they last
a minute the world's laziest play right
like I can't write anything that lasts
more than one minute or two minutes yeah
so I thought I can like write these
goofy little sketch ideas and then just
string them together somehow
yeah good think the write Death of a
Salesman Willy Loman been gone by page
four weren't you a cartoon guy did you
draw cartoons
I had a cartoon strip when I was in
college aha
did you use Madonna sketchy it was The
Adventures of Ned stick man he was III
I couldn't draw well that's about to say
that's great that's the best guy
couldn't draw well and so I knew it
would be hard for me to draw the same
guy twice so I had to make my main
character a stick man but he was the
only stick man everybody else was a like
a normal person and he was like a
superhero but he was flawed like if four
people were falling out of a building he
would catch three and then 1 1 would
splat and die but he caught three he did
cat that was my feeling is right the
world is better with him than without
him but there was still a dead guy 0%
body fat horses major flaw yeah cartoon
strip in college do people like it yeah
yeah it was uh I made an ED pin up one
time I had Ned looking all sexy and and
I had it in the college newspaper and we
would sell me and my buddy sold
sandwiches in the dorms and I saw Ned
pinups on all the other girls dorm walls
man and it was like so they were getting
into the humor of it now would you be
able to great would you be able to go up
to and be like you know I drew that and
if you did that would they go I'm like
is that sure would they go okay great
yes well Oh such a small school they
knew that I truly yeah there's only
about 40 people in the whole know it's
like a thousand students but where was
it
Heidelberg College oh that's a big one
what are you taking Heidelberg College
well I went there to be an economics
major but I ended up switching my major
to communication in theatre arts and
then art that's when I got into the
comedy deal okay did Ned stickman make
you a campus celebrity it did I loved
that it did there's nothing better
that's what I would walk around people
go you're the NED stickman guy and I
like that feeling of like wow people
recognition little thing you know yeah
you segue into how you were a campus no
no campus but I was not even close I'd
like I went to Syracuse much you know
it's a big school sure but when the
basketball team was winning the montage
men when the basketball team was winning
yeah oh my god they couldn't go anywhere
they were the biggest celebrities in the
world because you know they were loud
they were on campus this is a big
difference of listen at all huh there's
a big difference in the stick man I
don't think he was you weren't getting
showered with [ __ ] China the stick man
wasn't getting fit some vagina it's only
a thousand people at the school I
figured that is they're not gonna have a
wet n see a winning basketball team
right they got the stick man ah the team
[Laughter]
[Music]
stick man I was getting all the Broads
because of the football you hooked up a
lot in college I did I did
adequate then you take him on a date for
some cold spaghetti hey when you when
you get into your spaghetti Oh binges
you got you have a couple cocktails you
do chef he's our gedion meatball I'm
sorry when you going SpaghettiOs it's a
kid thing I wouldn't you're right I'm an
adult
I didn't mean to demean you raviolis
aren't bad either I like the Rebbe but
when you go when you get into that
eight you're getting ready you know
you're gonna have your chef boyardee but
you have a couple cocktails before that
do you avoid people while you're
intoxicated because you know you're
Brian Regan you don't want them to see
drunken Brian Regan or do you not care
no I care yeah I have to be careful with
that you know so uh but not so careful
[Laughter]
do you have it at home and just eat it
or is it a road tree I don't need it at
home you don't know it's are you still
in Vegas yeah
such a smart place to live because you
can get flights anywhere yeah it's been
new york too isn't it
no but Vegas with the weather you
probably have good weather too so you
probably be able to get in and out and
you know it's just it seems like a very
central place and I'm always flying
against the grain people fly into Vegas
on the weekends that's when I'm flying
out right I'm not dealing with the
security lines and all that it's not bad
when you're coming back in no one's
going to Vegas I'm [ __ ] exactly
Monday morning exactly I'm the only guy
did you fly into Vegas early Monday
morning your baggage ever get checked
and they're like what is this certain
you're like it's 17 cans of Chef
Boyardee it's really nothing to be
alarmed by with a metal detector wind
preserve wait do you check luggage uh
huh
hang on [ __ ] I am the worst I pack I
bring two suitcases why I don't know I
don't know how to pack light I never
could write you gonna wait an hour to
get your bag and drive me nuts
yeah [ __ ] alone for 10 days I'm just
wearing [ __ ] a bunch of time I can't I
said do it
Sam and my friend worked as a baggage
thrower and he's like don't ever check
and he's like we'd rape those things
they throw them around all over the
place so wait you'll go how long do you
go out for when you go there you're
doing theaters yeah but do you go out
it's usually four nights for
one-nighters Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday right okay and you'll wear a suit
each night no what do you wear jeans and
a maybe it may be a sport jacket how
many pints up shirt okay well you're a
little OCD I remember we got
last so is that you can't make a
decision on what you're gonna wear like
when you're packing you're not sure what
you wear one pair ring I bring more
stuff that I need okay sometimes and had
it how do you mean the OCD is it because
you see I gotta have this I gotta have
that like I meant one of this I want to
wear a different every night like
there's a hole like we were but I mean
like the whole thing if I'm not sure
what I'm gonna wear every night is
you're projecting your own mental
illness so you feel better but I was I'm
not even kidding I wear the same
underwear five days yeah do I wear my
underwear until I can smell them while
I'm walking I mean there's a comfortable
medium here you don't need to check bags
for four days but there's also no reason
to wear underwear five days
interferometers we're on two opposite
ends of the spectrum
underwear a second justjust yeah one you
know how I packing this a little crazy
so it's good one pair of underwear for
each day yeah that's what I do something
you might want to try some markjenner we
got seven seven pairs of undies yes in
pairs of panties that's a lot right it's
Roy if they're not soiled why change
them you can flip them inside out yeah
I'm not doing that man all right and
then I'm just gonna wear new underwear
every day
what about pants I were the same pants
for a year crazy I do I'd usually do
like I've gone for a week two to three
pairs of pants probably - Wow Bryan what
do you pack that you can't take and
carry on is there anything you bring
that like you can't fit me carry on
firearms oh yeah is it something like
that I have my [ __ ] pump pulled out once
that was embarrassed waiting a bit but
it's true but you might need it on the
plane so you better carry it on
I do you bring that gift you have to get
a small container of Lube because of the
liquid so you have travel size loop
dis Mart you bet I do really smart yep
Brian give trouble with the Lubin huh
man feeling awkward following that but I
don't know I bring my comedy folders
yeah you know with rough ideas and
things like that and I like I just
travel with them and I haven't learned
how to you know the job in my own puter
don't you yeah but do you need to pack
that spawners just carry on carry on
it's [ __ ] it's written jokes you
write a lot tell you I try you know I
try to do some new stuff every now and
then yeah Brian's really prolific then
yes yes you don't even go into laptop
you like the free man I should I'm
trying to switch over same way I just
kept these ruffled notes in my puck and
I can't look at all my friends go to
iPhone I can't do it you got jokes are
there no jokes
I'll talk them into my iPhone notes
because I do I get more worked on that
which I'm so [ __ ] lazy I'm talking in
write and I don't forget stuff that was
then you got to hear your dumb voice
later
no no into the notes it's just príncipe
right - now is she Siri that's advanced
really yeah you can do like I can talk
and it scripts it out for you yes hold
on dad I'll show you open up open up the
notes all right right and if I want to
just like say have a joke idea I can't
wait what I'm just glad that we get to
see a part of this process
yeah old woman with cancer falls down
steps president what did it say what
does it say old woman with cancer falls
down steps Wow Wow now I have that but I
just write in it you don't have to you
talking to it I know you gotta say that
at the airport right exactly
I don't do it into a microphone I do it
quietly all right it's totally likely
you're boarding and there's like a guy
right in front and a guy right behind
you and you're saying old woman with
cancer no then you laugh and then put
the phone back in your I'm getting I'm
playing I'll say something like bomb
amazing I'm surprised you do that now
they're never talking into my phone I
don't do that I mean just felt the same
way about radio microphone why would you
add the word radio
you see microphone that's right you know
what you're right I probably could have
just a little two already so for you I
mean you know other than phone calls
like I don't do the talk texting to any
of it voice memos a lot of people do
that now instead of texting like they
send voice memos so you get they talk
into the phone and then a recording
comes up in your text message and you
play and player I don't know a lot of
celebrities do it for somebody's exactly
it yeah I guess yeah I guess it's good
for the kids you know to give them say
normal voice messages I use that all
time for that what do you sound like
mono Monge
it's right there it's mono what are you
okay voice mail send your kids goodnight
things you know when you have one on
your phone huh you must have one context
I'd like to hear one yeah I can I
guarantee you having they save in your
audio I've sent the button my kids only
only not even two years old yet I don't
know how to do this stuff I need tips
you'll be the one then I should hear one
know why [ __ ] no you got more knowledge
today that's not a kid talking it is you
easily being a [ __ ] little cutesy
idiot that's great content yeah I'm
gonna be a bad father I need to know how
to do this I mean that's please
first of all isolate that and second
it's you can easily master this skill
it's like pretending you're kids there
and just say into the phone and I'll
talk to them I know I like that this
will be the lesson that makes you go
from a better father to a good phone
this is the turning point I had no idea
stop beating them first Travis do you
voice text your daughter no I'm usually
home when I say good night just
downstairs yeah I want to hear one
other's voice but I do too
cool Jim invites you in he shares his
home with you right 7 a.m. 7 a.m. like
water once you do the whole show
advertise your open mic how do them take
any doughnuts didn't take doughnuts I
ate the bagel you bought for me good for
you Travis your good friend and you
won't even resolve to I didn't even want
weed bag really now wiggle yeah hate it
who eats a wheat BAE know what I thought
it might help and you you won't even
share my most years lovely voicemail or
voice text or whatever
I mean Troy don't you think yeah come on
yeah what are you doing all the guys are
here we're all laugh and Brian's sitting
there going like this is really
disappointing like you having such a
good time a minute ago and then this
disappointed Brian Regan yeah come on
you want to do open mics again and you
got Brian Regan disappointed right do
you think that's the career okay not a
good love me no not a good luck
Oh Troy if the EDM people you know the
important one okay if they were like we
got to hear what's your voice text that
you send to your family are what are you
doing play it of course man up of court
you man up of course bad father bad
parable I think I'm actually being an
incredible father but I think so now
I've been on the other side as a bit
before he wants a high how much he loves
his kids yeah yeah no need to hide that
we're not gonna mock that that's not
mockable no good father say that Jim
because I don't want to get emotional
and weep I'm very emotional lately I can
tell I know that face you're about to
weep Jim don't don't let them take you
there why not he's manipulating you Jim
then go ahead take your phone out hey
guy what's hello joke let's see what it
sounds let's have a short one I got a no
just a quick one one one voice texture
one little voice to lean you're bullying
him who I used to work here so I know I
know that I know the deal don't we take
a vote I think a vote is fair a vote is
fair if if nobody wants to hear the
voice text we will not do it
and if but it is nice because Brian can
easily sit out the vote be the good guy
and still I'll lose the vote I'll
support I'm gonna support him hey guys
in one okay that's one vote for now
let's just say who would you vote no who
would like to hear fans voicemail to his
children yeah what is the you just say
goodnight okay exactly three four five
six [ __ ] love is in there but now we
have to finish the boat that's true who
would not like to hear it who
now okay let's count these up okay one
shoe mark have you abstained I don't get
I don't care I don't think it'll be that
good that's a no 4 to 3 or 6 to 6 to 3
in favor of yes okay so we'll go ahead
and to landslide victory for play voice
dev I'm are getting the voice sorry yeah
man I do have a doughnut I don't know no
I I'm familiar with how these things
work yeah really not apparently you are
not yeah I shouldn't have even brought
it up in the first no because you're
disappointing everybody that's right
everybody sad now that's probably
specially brushy yeah it's very little
you know air kisses and whatnot so an
impression of this could be a great
sketch on the show yeah I think so and
when's it out the show Christmas Eve
Chrissy great I can't wait are they
dropping all four at once oh that's the
way to do it the the binge-watching
thing well if people want to watch them
well yeah
Christmas Eve is also yeah I mean that's
a good time to drop it cuz that's the
time that everybody's at home and yeah
actually has some time to binge yes yes
yeah I I can be so bold I'm on another
thing called Loudermilk
oh yeah it's a Peter Farrelly directed
series about substance abuse we just got
picked up for a third season
that's great party who do you play I
play Mugsy which is I'm recovering from
substance abuse and estranged from my
family and the whole thing and sounds
funny as hell but but it is it's it's
good who else it are honest and who else
Ron Livingston is in it oh no Will Sasso
Oh
those are the two bigger names and it's
uh written some good heat ain't emts
audience networks yeah see how many
places there are to put content now it's
great right like something that ABC
might have said no to you could do here
you could do it on Amazon you don't know
there's a million place I'm I'm a major
network would have never ever done this
show why is it the cursing order a
little of both you know it's very you
know the Farrelly Brothers yeah yeah
Larkin twisty and foul language and that
sort of thing but it's real you know
gritty I mean it's so nice that they
have all those outlets not just because
because then a show like this can come
out and they don't have to change it so
that they can get it on a network they
go this is the show exactly so it's a
good show either way there's gonna be a
spot for it
well Peter Farrelly I heard him talking
saying it's weird that movies and TV
have flipped completely it used to be
movies is where you would see
interesting content and TV was the more
hack oriented stuff and now with so many
networks like you're talking about you
can do interesting stuff on TV and
movies is all see no holes
oh yeah superheroes superheroes Yeah
right things that look better on a big
screen yeah yeah and and familiarity
like people need I feel like people need
they go to the theater and they need to
know exactly what the process is like I
saw Creed 2 and creature was a good
movie but I was sitting there going you
didn't even need to necessarily hire a
writer for this exact because you knew
exactly from beginning to end how this
thing was gonna go before you even
walked in and then like Jumanji I got a
remake that it's like that's maybe that
old mega Jumanji I know I know I didn't
see the new one I like the old one oh
yeah that's fun they're redoing clueless
jeez
yes if [ __ ] that's right because a
lot of the minds growing up this they
just grew up watching movies yeah
recreate in the same [ __ ] it's weird
they remade Footloose and stuff okay
literal interpretation of the film in
the new in the remake of footman with
some hot guy yes a couple years ago kid
yeah no Kevin Bacon
now he was the cutest of the kids let's
hear it for the boys yeah um
there it is yeah who was it was it I
Derek ha for somebody they don't need to
remake that's a [ __ ] dancing well I
know did John Lithgow reprise his role
know who truly aunt Huff Dennis Dennis
Quaid Andie MacDowell Oh
gives a [ __ ] about this movie nobody
nobody saw it we have the same Sawyer
they read you the song so I'm sure would
I would think this is it you know remake
this is the remake of it you can't tell
the difference yeah kick off your sunday
shoes to dump [ __ ] it's song anyway
that's so old I think they should be
doing a remake of the relay yeah we
already yeah yeah that's they did with
Halloween I mean Halloween they did the
remake in the early in like the mid
2000s and then they came back and I
guess technically this is a sequel but
really mm-hmm it's a remake like Creed
technically it's a rocky sequel but it's
a remake that was really good it's a
trap when they burn him well that's
really great they burned up in [ __ ]
Halloween - your stillness you're still
pissed about the beard I am pissed about
the beard and they burned him in
Halloween - it's a good move shut his
eyes out Halloween - didn't happen it
did it did not shot his [ __ ] eyes out
they're not brother and sister what's
spider-man are we on now let's go late
the fort is a cartoon now spider-man the
cartoon after the spider-verse everybody
loves it you see the spider verse damn I
can't wait - I have not I've heard the
music in it is very good but other than
that I don't know I can't comment